I'm pretty sure this movie takes place
in one month that month No Shave
November seriously look at that [ __ ] if
anyone in November can reach beard
magnitude Moses you win life why grow my
hair out because I can't use that Exodus
gods and Kings Exodus gods and Kings is
a telling of the story of Exodus you
know Moses and Pharaoh let my people go
plagues of Egypt parting of the Red Sea
more beards you burn it you get it in
this movie Christian Bale plays moses
and joel edgerton Edgerton or Edgerton I
do I've heard both Joel plays Ramses
Christian Bale's like a brother to him
then he does something gets booted out
of his kingdom finds another group of
people to hang out with and then gods
like hey you got to go back there and
get my people out of there and I was
really digging this movie as this movie
was going along I was like alright I
like I like Christian Bale I like joel
edgerton I like them together Ramses in
this movie is kind of a brat let's be
honest he's gonna have a dick you know
like Moses is that guy you're like oh
yeah you should be running Egypt
Ramses in those movies like the spoiled
kid who will end up running the place
you're like ah not that brat the scope
with this movie is enormous you look
around you like yes that's why I wanted
to see this movie I wanted to see a
modern telling you the story of Moses
because Egypt is gonna look big and
grand which is what Egypt was they were
not modest by any stretch of the
imagination it's good to see that on
screen you really felt it and I love
Christian Bale's portrayal of Moses in
this movie Moses is not what you think
he's gonna be he's not like Ramses let
my people go yes I have on shaking faith
I am a rock no he's really human you can
tell he does not want to go and do this
thing but he has to even when he's there
in the plagues of Egypt are hitting he's
like can we stop like good people or in
the cross fires this is kind of this
kind of a dick move don't do this I like
the fact that he's not just black or
white he's in that shade of grey where a
lot of us live and the plagues looked
awesome in this movie they tried to do
that thing look kind of like Hilary
Swank in that well I forgot what movie
it was there's a movie where Hilary
Swank is this investigator investigating
this paranormal thing she doesn't
believe in the paranormal and she spouts
out all of the plagues of Egypt
scientifically how they would have
happened that's what this movie does so
it kind of makes it accessible like oh
gods use them science oh that's cool and
I do feel like there was a wasted
opportunity with
Moses and Rameses you know like they're
like brothers at the beginning of the
movie and then it goes away and then he
comes back and he has words with them
and then really they never have a
face-to-face until it's all ending it
would have been great for these two
characters to have dialogue together so
you can see their Brotherhood just being
torn in half it would have kept you
engaged in the movie more and ultimately
the parting of the Red Sea no movie like
this is supposed to be the big send-off
for Superman the sea parts it's supposed
to be this grand like oh my god we win
we win life No Shave November style we
did it but after the plagues like AHA
plagues and everything looks scary
because the plagues are just really vile
in this movie and even the cliff falls
in half then you get to the scene it's
kind of like literacy it's this
underwhelming thing comparatively
speaking to all the other events that
have happened in this movie leading up
to the parting of the say Indian Exodus
gods and Kings had great performance as
a thought Christian Bale was great Joel
Edgerton was Grimer to say entertain I
love the epic scope of it Egypt has
never looked better or more grand the
plagues were great they were frightening
I loved how they did it but it did have
some missed opportunities with Moses and
Rameses and the parting of the sea the
end of the movie was kind of
underwhelming do you feel the movie
still chugging along you're like all
right you're checking your watch look
now you can and just end you can feel
it's like you're at a comedy club and
that light in the backs flashing like
all right man
wrap it up wrap I can't do that at the
same that's hard in the end I had a good
time with it and it was an interesting
take on the Moses story so I will say
Exodus gods and Kings is a good time no
alcohol required where's Alexis gods and
Kings have you seen it what did you
think about it like Prince of Egypt you
did whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you liked what
you seen here and you want to see more
click right here to see more